I guess we're you know this we were
originally planning on talking about
this story in in like the segment we
were doing on coronavirus because the
Dow Jones has rallied 1294 points the
most in its history that's insane
so it dropped the most in history up and
then recovered and recovered the most
but this was so obvious you know what
man I kind of feel bad for the people
who went who panicked and scold okay I
kept saying don't panic it's we're gonna
be fine there's gonna be some
disruptions so I'll tell you what man
some people bought the dip we probably
just saw a bunch of people become
millionaires yeah because it was so
obvious to anybody we were look the
market was at like twenty nine thousand
something points and I know for most
people is probably meaningless right it
basically means if you've got a
retirement account which a lot of people
do or if you have some stocks or
whatever people saw a lot depending
depend on the stocks you had but
people's like retirement accounts 401ks
took a hit everyone's panicking and then
all of a sudden smart people came in and
started buying the dip and now it's
spiked and they just got to enjoy a
record big the biggest gain ever so it
did is it actually higher than it was
before it even dropped I think it is no
no it's not and that's what I thought oh
because it dropped 1,000 the first day
and then like I kept going so we were at
29 we fell down to like 24 something I
know these numbers are plain meaningless
in the average person and what it was
right right and so there's there's
there's still a long way to go back to
recover but foot this way that's like I
mean what are we looking at like a 12% I
think those are 12% drop altogether yeah
so if you if you bought in when it went
to the bottom and it's now recovering
you are gonna end up making a huge
return in a day
some people just got rich some people
probably made crazy bets cuz think about
it why would the market go down because
people were panicking because the news
of a corona virus why would the market
go up because we're now realizing it
wasn't that big of a deal it is serious
I mean it still feels like we're in that
territory oh it does it could swing
still and you know like the corona virus
could some like in me we
in three days we could find out it's in
30 States and there's 20,000 cases I
don't we don't know about I don't think
it's gonna go down I mean maybe maybe
it's a false sense of security but I'll
tell you what if somebody bought in the
dip and sold right now they'd have just
sold at the biggest gain in history
yeah or point again I guess I mean that
percentage I hope they spend the money
they just earned on supplies on
precooked polenta which can be eaten for
breakfast lunch and dinner for those for
those that are watching the clip
wondering what that reference was it was
from the chat which you get from the
full-length podcast well let's let's see
what CNN business says I you know I do
feel like this a bit uh so terrible
because it's a historical moment I think
it's important to talk about even if
people might not be super interested
sure they say US stocks rebounded
sharply on Monday with the Dow logging
its biggest point gain in history stocks
are coming off their worst week since
the 2008 financial crisis the Dow last
week dropped twelve point four percent
while the SNP plunged 11.5 percent yikes
the Dow also recorded its worst one-day
point drop in history on Thursday quote
if the market is priced to perfection
and then something indicates the
perfection is a pipe dream prices will
come off said brad cornell emeritus
professor of finance at UCLA of last
week's sell-off prices are much more
reasonable now he added but monday's
rebound was strong after a sharply
higher open and some flipping between
gains and losses mid morning stocks
moved solidly higher the Dow finished up
1294 points or 5.1 percent making it the
best one-day point gain on record on a
percentage basis monday was its best day
since march 2009 the S&P climbed 4.6 the
best performance since December 2018 the
rise in both indexes snapped a seven day
losing streak the Nasdaq Composite
closed up 4.5% all three indexes are now
less than 10% from their highs they
entered a correction last week which is
defined as a 10% decline from the most
recent highs I just don't think that's
fair though I think that turts is weird
right it's like it's like implying the
market did something when in fact it was
like a natural disaster of essentially
that caused the the prices to fluctuate
yeah a correction and like I get it I
get it
I'm not the expert on this stuff but a
correction feels like they're saying
that
price shouldn't have been that high for
you know one reason and then the market
literally just sold off when in reality
it's like a eighty thousand people in
China got sick and the government
cracked down and shut factories down and
supply chain got disrupted so and that's
why I think it's spiking because it's
not it's it's the price should be higher
I think everyone recognizes that - we're
not everybody but enough people
investors are pushed and pulled in two
different directions by headlines about
the novel coronavirus outbreak on the
one hand the Organisation for Economic
Cooperation and Development warned
Monday that the outbreak could
significantly slow down global growth
meanwhile hopes for stimulus action
around from the world central banks are
keeping investors from further selling
the Bank of Japan said it would provide
ample liquidity to keep financial
markets stable and the Bank of England
also pledged to do what's necessary for
the British economy stability the
Federal Reserve next meets on March 18th
and market expectations for for a half
percentage point interest rate cut are
at a hundred percent according to the
CME's Fed watch - I gotta I gotta admit
this is a lot of this is just so
esoteric like I don't know how many
people pay attention to banking and
numbers and everything I don't I don't
know what this is
well I'm clueless here I don't so I was
saying I was made a joke maybe I should
invest on Friday
I shouldn't have been joking I'm over
here kicking there's there's what is it
Robin Hood everyone got really mad at
Robin Hood something and went down and
people were trying to sell the market
went down so hard they shut it down
Robin Hood was like wow well it seemed
like Robin Hood saved a lot of people
money because now it's bouncing back up
not if you were trying to buy bro not if
you're trying to buy the ultra you're
trying to buy and now you're like so I'm
gonna sue Robin Hood I bet I bet mad
people are all put it this way you know
cuz I'm reading a lot these numbers and
I gotta admit a certain point talking
about the percentage gains and losses
I'm kind of just like I get it the
markets doing well what does that mean
right so a lot of people were claiming
that first like the correction is
because the markets bad and it's
inflated and it shouldn't be that high
they're pumping out money and all that
stuff and it's like then we would see a
real correction not a coronavirus
correction right I mean look I'm not an
economist so I know I'm gonna get my my
head shoot off in the emails people are
gonna I get it all the time they're like
you have no idea you're talking I was
like dude I just read
News I'm not I'm not sitting down and
doing math finally you know you're also
not claiming to be an expert I say that
every time I am yeah that's right yeah
no but what a lot of people are trying
to claim that this is proof that the
accounting economy we've been seeing
with like record low unemployment and
like them that the the record stock
numbers keep going up and it's fake and
I think this actually shows it's not I
mean you can you can argue that a lot of
people have sent me talking about like
the banks pumping out money but when you
have all of these different news outlets
and I don't necessarily think you should
trust them saying recovery good numbers
and then we have certain political
figures lying about how good things are
you yeah but why politicians lie
surprise surprise
yeah no I think we're doing I think
we're doing really great I think you
know III I try I suppose we could talk a
little bit about politics I don't want
to go you know crazy but they there's a
lot of people who want the economy to do
bad and that's what scared me cuz we
heard it from Bill Maher he'd said I
don't know you this is this is from a
few months ago okay
Bill Maher actually said on his show
bring on the recession because it'll get
rid of Trump
I remember hearing that yeah you don't
happens when when we hit bad recessions
people lose their house will get hurt
yeah they lose their houses they get
sick the cancer and it's because just to
get rid of Trump these people don't like
the man so much that they are they're
cheering for it so when we got that big
market hit I mean there were people like
that they were like yes they were
cheering for the tanking of this you go
on Twitter like this proves everything
we've been saying it's like gloating
dude like people or people's retirement
accounts are tied up in this first of
all no it doesn't this is directly
related to what looks like a global
pandemic
they don't care like Bill Maher actually
talked about on the show where he was
like he was like I know a lot of people
are mad at me for saying bring on the
recession but oh you know I think yeah
he said yeah exactly I mean it seriously
yeah and the 2008 recession doubled down
on it like
there I grew up hearing stories like the
Great Depression with people jumping out
windows I mean that's and I think that's
crazy I mean I get it some people lose
their mark or seen anything like it
everything yeah but if they had just
waited a lot of people people recovered
vested in I guess but then in 2008 -
I'll tell you a story man I used to I
was crashing at my buddy's floor right
so this was back when how old it was was
I was 12 years ago I was like 21 20
years old and so I'm crashed my buddy's
couch I say floor cuz I'm trying to you
know exaggerate a little bit no I'm
sleeping on his couch and I looked up on
Craigslist I need a job
dishwasher there's a dishwasher job and
it paid minimum wage I'm like I can wash
dishes I don't know what else I was
doing I'll sleep on the couch so I show
up there and my resume is like a really
scrappy piece of paper and I I'm walking
up and I you know ass like the hostess
um do you want to drop off a resume for
the dishwashing position she's like yeah
just right in back and I walk forward
and there's a guy wearing a suit with a
briefcase and this was like right after
the economic collapse and I'm standing
behind him and I'm like I wonder what
this guy's here for and when the manager
walks out I hear him go
I'm here to inquire about the
dishwashing position and he like hands a
resume and I was like okay and I turned
around it's walked out that dude is
probably way overqualified for that job
though he probably did know for sure I
know but he probably needed it more than
well no no I was basically like homeless
housing I needed the job no but but I'll
chalk it up to being a dumb ignorant I
was like there's no way I'm competing
with this guy what
bounine but in reality if I showed up
wearing like you know ripped jeans and I
was like I want to wash dishes they'd be
like that's the guy who's gonna wash
dishes and not leave right away right
yeah exactly ality I'm the person who
would leave right away cuz I'd like I
bet I'd make a couple hundred bucks in a
month and be like well now I got my you
know rent for the next couple months
covered and but but no I mean when it
when it comes to I've got a guy in
assuming hey hey when it comes to the
guy in the suit yeah they're not gonna
hire him I mean I don't think people res
how bad it got that there were people
who literally couldn't get any job and
then had like a lot of people got really
depressed started on popping pills or
beginning getting drunk so here's here's
the crazy thing that happens when
markets get really not necessarily when
markets get bad but the economy itself
is there's this this down chain effect
where you've got a baby boomer tons of
experienced senior management right all
of a sudden there's mass layoffs
now that senior level manager is
competing with a millennial manager and
so when they show up to an office job in
new
and they say we offer 50k a year and
this guy used to make a hundred they're
like the most we can afford is this this
guy's not gonna take the leave this job
because the economy's bad and then they
turn to the Millennial and say no job
for you so the Millennial goes down to
the dishwashing position and then the 16
year olds don't have jobs so where you
want like you know 16 year olds to be
doing the dishwashing I'm gonna turn
disrespect kids but you wanted to be
doing entry-level low-level work
somewhere right pretty soon we're gonna
have robots doing the dishes they're
gonna be stealing those the are you
already do yeah we do all they do now is
a lot of placing matter time they put
the dishes in the machine and press the
button and they bring it out and the
dishes are done it's that that the
magical dishwasher device it is called
the dishwasher that's right I knew it no
I things to you now - I got a picture
for my family today and it was this
little robot that was going up and down
the aisles in Walmart and it was taking
inventory you know that thing that it
used to take like yeah 15 people like 16
days to do that while people were
shopping around it oh there you go cool
Andrew Yang was right the revolution is
here and yeah but I think I guess the
more relevant discussion on the market
the good news it's rallying back up the
biggest gain in history which means so
will it continue I think so okay I think
I think it will I mean don't take my
advice I'm not a financial expert anyway
I'm talking about
I've got like one stock and I don't
really pay attention for the most part
but I think the bigger issue is whether
or not you are gonna have a job you are
gonna get paid and I think this isn't
gonna change any of that this is gonna
affect people who are so that there will
be a ripple effect for sure but for the
most part thing I think we're to be fine
and I think you know the phenomenon they
want to talk about before is that when
the recession hit it pushed out
Millennials and so now they were
stagnating and it's one of the reasons I
think Millennials you know aren't
getting families aren't buying houses
yeah is that they got stunted by their
the Great Recession and they weren't
working higher career jobs they were
working low level crap jobs and this did
it did the same thing to Gen Z right it
pushed them out so they weren't getting
jobs a lot of these people then said
let's go to college instead now they
racked up debt you can see how all of
this is a chain of you know effect the
good news is the reason I bring this up
bring this up is with how good the
economy has been over the past couple
years
this is now going to have a pulling
effect in the other direction and start
scooping everybody back up in the right
direction and maybe be the real
correction we've been looking for with
like this crummy economy yeah you know I
mean like it was it was crummy in 2008
bring in the young bloods bring in the
young bloods now they can start working
office jobs because now we got the
sixteen year olds washing dishes again
and get younger people in government
definitely Donald Donald Trump is the
youngest man running for president for a
major political party
out of all of them Donald Trump is the
youngest contender for the see Tim 7373
what did Buddha judge drop out
yeah but she's but I mean Warren's
younger but it's like way way way hold
on she's 70 do we have any politicians
like for a mate like I mean Paul C is
still running but in terms of like the
mainstream TV like yeah who we think
will win on frontrunner Trump is the
youngest man he's a strapping young lad
compared to the other guys well he
actually does look looks like he can
handle he could probably beat them in a
fight all right I do I'd agree versus
one I mean hold on first of all Mike
Bloomberg is like five feet tall Bernie
Sanders has a heart attack I was talking
about and you know Joe Biden would walk
in the wrong direction and swinging at
the trees
he'd be like oh [ __ ] I got him horn pop
corn pop where are you at and then he'd
fall off the stage and then Trump would
be going like this excuse me excuse me
Joe I'm over here excuse me Joe would be
gone and he'd be holding holding all the
Bloomberg like this Donald Trump you get
your hand off my head I've got money I'm
the only real billionaire here okay okay
Trump's holding his head back they're
all crazy as far as I'm concerned but I
will say one one last thing on this one
we can go to the super Jets I think it's
absolutely insane that they're gonna
nominate Biden that dude doesn't he he
said super Thursday you saw that super
Thursday and then he corrected himself
because like because I know what he's
talking about he was like listen super
Thursday to Tuesday's come in and
everyone are laughing
they're not gaffes dude the guys
literally let me say like 150 million
150 million people died since 2000 since
2007 that's half our population people
half of the country died I didn't know
yeah well no there was a civil war Ian
we should do a subject the whole thing
we should we should we should film ask
it of like via The Forgotten Civil War
yeah that no one knows about thanks for
checking out this segment from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show every
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
sometimes an hour or two and we do have
a full live recorded version of the show
that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you